welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and Jordan Peel's nope was one of
the scariest and most unsettling movies
of this year and it is now yours to own
now a digital 4K UHD Blu-ray and DVD
which is amazing because the more you
look into the special features and bonus
content of this movie The more you
realize how Jordan peels somehow made us
all terrified of horse ranches north of
La using super well thought out creature
design and subliminal techniques that
really get under your skin I'm gonna
break down why this movie is so scary
and this video itself May freak you out
spoiler warning for nope if you have not
seen the movie yet you definitely should
it's a really great creepy night in this
time of year which is why you should get
it so nope tells the story of a family
of horse trainers the Haywood on their
Ranch in Agua Dulce which is stalked by
what they think is a flying saucer
hiding in plain sight it's a cloud until
they realize that it's actually a
floating Predator animal that they
nicknamed jean jacket jean jacket
devours people and horses through its
Central orifice eating anything that
makes eye contact with it from the
opening Bible verse from the prophet
Nahum I will belt you with built I will
treat you with contempt and make you a
spectacle Jordan Beale established nope
as a film all about the concept of
spectacle I think the DNA of the movie
has this big question about the human
addiction to spectacle and what happens
when money becomes involved in that that
there's this sort of massive
exploitation of what should be pure and
what should be natural Jordan bill
Floyd's two psychological fears our fear
of the depths and our fear of eye
contact literally our anxiety over not
being able to see something and our
anxiety overseeing someone or something
that has also seen us these anxieties
are encoded into pretty much all human
beings and both of these are woven into
the design of jean jacket both its look
and its function so let's start with the
fear of the depths jean jacket is alien
but also Vaguely Familiar to us and
that's because it's based entirely on
sea life in the nope special features
you learn about how peel consulted with
Caltech marine life expert John DeBerry
to base the creature's design
specifically on a jellyfish they
themselves are actually 95 water so that
helps them to be able to float The
Entity sitting in the clouds is kind of
the same idea taking advantage of being
about the same density as the
surrounding air they are able to be very
stealthy in terms of moving through the
water without being detected think about
it if you've ever gone swimming in the
ocean and gotten stung by a jellyfish
you likely remember that acute fear the
very next time you went in the water
what else may be lurking just out of
grass that I might accidentally make
contact with every design feature of
this monster from the way it silently
floats nearly invisibly the way it
unfurls to these crazy Dimensions the
way the string of flags hangs from the
cloud like a stinger are all visual
elements that are inspired by a
jellyfish equally important to the
design of jean jacket is the way it
sounds Jordan Peele also talked about
how its sounds are based on the way some
ocean creatures use echolocation we've
got one that we'll just call the click
which is like
predator sound the idea is it's one part
echolocation like a dolphin because the
vision's not very good it also has a
little bit of this element of bringing
your attention up to the sky and then of
course there's the terrifying way jean
jacket devours its prey through that
Central orifice a sand dollar absorbs
and excretes through a similar Central
orifice on its bottom side and since
this absorption is drawn out peel
revealed in another bonus clip that's
simply the sounds of human screams were
mixed into its overall sound every time
we heard it my favorite sound that the
UFO makes is the sound of people
screaming perhaps what's most terrifying
about the way power UFO abducts is that
when you're inside it's not an instant
death
you're in there for a while and it's not
a good place to be but this
this spray only
which brings us to the second personal
anxiety that we talked about before eye
contact I'm sorry I'm not helping right
now if you really want to freak yourself
out re-watch this movie and think of the
creature as a giant eyeball an eye in
the sky daring you to look back at it
after that opening quote about spectacle
Steven Yeun who plays Joop in this movie
talks about how his character never
learned that lesson from his childhood
Trauma from jupe's point of view feel
very natural feel very like this is the
next step and it all makes sense until
it culminates to that moment where he
realizes that he has masterminded and
constructed his own destruction and from
the movie's opening quote about
spectacle the movie's opening credits
set us in the most horrifying hell that
the film has to offer inside the belly
of the Beast all we really see in these
credits is the disorienting square shaft
but we have no idea what we're looking
at yet until later in the film we think
back on it and realize wait this is what
the victims of jean jacket see as they
are being digested that square remember
is both the creature's mouth but also
it's Iris how it feeds and how it sees
at the climax of the movie we see it's a
large green square shape unfurling in a
hypnotic ribbony dance over and over
again on itself it's both beautiful and
terrifying and that green square shape
if you watch closely subliminally haunts
us again and again throughout the movie
at the end of the opening credits we
arrive at the famous square footage of
the black jockey on the racehorse the
first motion picture the history that M
delightfully lectures us about during
that commercial shoot in front of what
is that a giant green square on jupe's
desk in his office a green box
containing feathered pens and quills
with a matching green cover for a pair
of scissors of course another Jordan
Peele Easter egg from us later in the
movie when the security camera window
loses its signal due to Jean jacket's
interference that window now forms a
green square troops paper flyer for a
star lasso experience covered in horse
droppings this is the way Jupe lassos in
horses and people to beat the jean
jacket another green square really one
of the most mind-blowing green squares
hidden in plain sight the giant green
present box on the set of Gordy's home
the violent incident that opens the film
The Box containing the balloons that pop
and Trigger Gordy now in the movie it is
a clear green box but the note bonus
features show how when they shot that
scene that prop was not as sharply green
it was more of a seafoam or teal that
this movie's editors and colorists
shaded in post-production to a solid
green color to better fit with this
green square Motif I swear I'm not
making this up the movie's editor
actually confirmed this in an interview
that this green square symbolism
throughout the film was fully
intentional from him and Jordan Peele
and why do they do this again spectacle
this whole movie is designed to be a
meta self-reflection on the dangers of
looking at something for too long and
getting sucked into it and what better
way to illustrate that than craft this
entire film into the monster itself
sucking Us in again Jordan beale's nope
is now available to buy and to stream
it's yours to own now on digital 4K UHD
Blu-ray and DVD follow me on Tick Tock
Instagram and Twitter at eavos follow
new Rockstar subscribe to your rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]